[MUSIC]
I want to share with you today a story
about Israelis and Palestinian,
but it's not about war and
it's not about conflict.
It's a story of the technology bridge that
we're building between the two people.
So the story starts on
an aeroplane in 2017,
I opened my eyes just as the pilot
announced our descent onto Israel.
I could see the Aviv Skyline shining
brightly in the distance and
can make out the logos of Facebook and
Google wicks in ways plastered on
the facades of the high rises home.
But this time, I was going as part of
a delegation from Washington there to
observe different policy trends and
shifting dynamics.
Looking at my home through
a fresh set of eyes,
I was amazed by the technology boom
that my country was experiencing.
With over 7,000 startups,
400 multinationals, and 84 unicorns,
Israel was one of the most advanced
technological ecosystems on the planet,
and had earned the nickname
of Start-Up Nation.
But it wasn't all great,
Start Up nation was in danger,
one of our speakers informed us.
She presented us with this report put
together by the Israeli innovation
authority that stated
that at any given moment,
there were over 15,000 job openings and
technical startups and
tech companies, and that those companies
are just struggling to fill them.
This was huge technology is by far
Israel's greatest economic driver.
And now it was at a danger of hitting
a glass ceiling because of a shortage and
engineers.
The next day, I went on my first
visit to a Palestinian city.
As an Israeli citizen,
I'm not allowed to go into Palestinian
cities without a special permit.
And I could feel the tension
building in my body
as we made it into
the unfamiliar territory.
Had a lot of preconceptions about
what the city might look like,
how hostile it may feel.
Those are all shattered to soon as he made
it into the beautiful city of Rawabi.
The heart of the Palestinians Tech
sector that happens to
be just a little over an hour's drive
from the home that I grew up in.
In Rawabi, we were greeted by a panel of
engineers that told us that every year
3000 Palestinian software engineers
graduated into the labor market,
but that over 90% of
them were unable to find
jobs in the Steel Nathan Palestinian
tech sector.
I looked at my colleagues,
were they hearing this?
A shortage of 15,000 engineers
in Israeli companies,
and an hour away thousands of
Palestinians engineers looking for
jobs, could these pieces be connected?
I certainly thought that they could,
in fact I was so convinced that I started
Tech Bridge, an organization that
connected Israeli and Palestinian tech.
We worked with Israeli tech companies,
with job openings and
we encourage them to fill those
openings with Palestinian talent.
Some were wary,
they were just convinced that employing
Palestinian engineers is not a good idea.
But most were simply excited,
they had no idea that there were
Palestinian software engineers looking for
jobs, and we're excited by
the opportunity to hire local talent.
We also worked with Palestinian software
engineers straight out of college
creating a training program for them to
hone in on those hard skills and gain
that a little bit of experience before
landing that first job out of college.
Now Tech Brigde is just one of many
incredible organizations working to
enhance cross border collaborations
between the Israeli and
Palestinian tech ecosystems.
And today, we have nearly 1000 Palestinian
software engineers working for
Israeli Startups, and
Israeli branches of multinationals.
So, Mellanox for example, an Israeli
company that was recently sold for
$7 billion, employs over 150
Palestinian software engineers,
30 of them working remotely out of Gaza.
Kratos and Israeli Startup in
the freight industry actually
established an R&D center in Ramadan,
a Palestinian city.
And we are already seeing
X Kratos employees going and
starting their own ventures, fueling
the Palestinian tech ecosystems and
creating new jobs, and
hopefully this is just the beginning.
Now there's so much more that I would
love to tell you about the challenges and
opportunities in this space.
But the next few minutes, I want to share
with you what excites me most about it.
So first, I'm excited about
Palestinian software engineers
working with Israeli tech companies,
because it's simply an obvious
market solution to a market problem.
Has incredible positive externalities,
but at its core,
it's business driven,
which ensures its organic growth.
You have a demand for
engineers on the Israeli side, and
you have a supply of engineers looking for
jobs on the Palestinian side.
We've all learned in
introductory microeconomics,
barring structural barriers, market forces
will lead these two into equilibrium.
In other words, it just makes business
sense to match Palestinian software
engineers looking for
jobs with Israeli tech company.
The second reason that I'm excited about
this space is because it's a rare instance
where tangible action does not benefit one
side at the expense of the other side,
but rather creates a win-win situation
benefiting both Israelis and Palestinians.
And increasing economic prosperity
in the region as a whole.
So instead of dividing the pie like in so
many other instances related to
Israel Palestinian relations,
we're actually enlarging the pie.
And finally, the third reason that
I'm excited about this space,
is that it's simply an opportunity for
us to get to know each other.
As Israelis,
many of us have never met a Palestinian.
And when we hear the word Palestinian,
it's often connected with violence.
And many Palestinians have only
seen Israeli soldiers would they
are taught to view as their enemies.
And suddenly you have Israelis and
Palestinians working shoulder to shoulder,
it's an incredible opportunity for
us to get to know each other to replace
Alien Nation with familiarity and
to replace that faceless enemy with
a friendly face So,
why am I telling you guys all of this?
Most of you are neither Israeli nor
Palestinian, many of you are in tech and
I hope you find these market
opportunities as exciting as I do.
But even if you don't,
I'm going to take a bet here and
say that all of you have read about
Palestinians and Israelis in the news, or
had a conversation about
the Israeli Palestinian conflict in
the past year and thought to yourself,
this is hopeless.
So, I wanted to share this story with you
today to give you a fresh perspective,
a story of hope rather
than one of despair.
So even if you have no connection to the
region whatsoever, this is my ask of you.
The next time you read about
Palestinians and Israelis in the news,
remember that there's also good
news coming out of the region.
Flip to the business section
of the newspaper and look for
the next Israeli Palestinian founded
unicorn, and help bring a breath
of fresh air into the global
conversation of a decade old conflict.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]